foreign
[Applause]
Ted gays please report to the
principal's office that's up to you guys
tonight is our night we're getting the
couch I'm gonna talk to Brittany you get
that Isabel what would I say hey girl
how's your boyfriend how's his penis
[Music]
I'm gonna expel you both for committing
a crime against Jeff get out of the car
you can't tell me
we were just practicing for a
self-defense Club it's like a Fight Club
yes just stay in your lane into your
munching Beaver Wesleyan yes sir
what's your plan here Jeff is psychotic
and they're picking on the weak and
defenseless so we teach a bunch of girls
how to defend themselves they are
grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
you can be our club advisor you know my
mom did say I need to pick up a hobby
Club
[Music]
[Applause]
I have a safe space like this it means a
lot to people I'm gonna finally reverse
stalk my stalker yeah I'll be able to
kill my stepdad awesome he seems so
supportive of women especially the hot
ones man-made therapy
are you cheating on me
I literally saw you yesterday
we are literally at the bottom we have
nowhere to go but up
[Music]
his
they deserve a shot at showing everybody
how cool they are
a place
created a Fight Club to get some coochie
I know y'all ain't tickling the Pearl I
just don't know if you're supposed to be
talking to us like that just like as a
teacher